Pineapple Express meets D&D yeah let's
do it your highness
now your highness is like one of those
medieval quest movies with a lot of pot
and dick jokes and it stars two brothers
one who's like the shining Knight of
Awesome and the other who's the shitty
little brother that no one cares about
so it's pretty much Boromir and Farah
meer of Boromir was James Franco and
Farah Mir was a really fat stoner no in
Your Highness James Franco's fiance
played by Zooey Deschanel so how you
pronounce your last name that's how I'm
gonna say it I'm gonna say do Chanel has
been kidnapped by a warlock do doesn't
get booed off stage yeah that guy and
the whole thing is when the moon's
eclipse the warlocks gonna bang the
chick and she's gonna give birth to a
dragon and then they're gonna get the
Cataclysm expansion they don't want that
yeah that douche and they have to go
quest to get her back and along the way
they run into Natalie Portman who's this
really hot yeah she's still hunt this
was pre pregnant Natalie Portman badass
warrior chick who does not take
from anyone who can kick anyone's ass
and does not cook which could mean only
one thing
lesbian now this movie was pretty funny
I didn't like it as much as I wanted to
I really wanted to like this movie
because I really like pineapple Express
and the best I can figure it's like the
crew of pineapple Express was playing
D&D while playing Warcraft while at a
Renaissance Faire and that just sounds
like all sorts of awesome that I would
love but it was a nice bit of Awesome
that I generally liked the jokes in this
movie are way too like in-your-face I
like jokes that take a bit of brains to
figure it out this one's like oh it's a
dick joke yeah there you go and I
understand pop movies even if they're
like medieval fantasy movies aren't like
rocket science it's not like brain
surgery you don't need like a four-year
degree or even a high school diploma to
figure them out but the hero just seemed
a little cheap I mean it's not meant to
be taken seriously and I know that it's
a total slap in the tits - all things
medieval fantasy just in the way they
talk - like brother we must go and quest
to get her back and it's exaggerated and
it's funny but I just think that's
funnier than just you know a Minotaur
dick hanging around a neck although I
laughed when they just said that but you
know what I mean it is pretty funny
though in comparing it to pineapple
Express which is what I'm gonna do a lot
I felt the humor and pineapple Express
was a bit smarter it doesn't mean I
didn't laugh in this movie I did I
laughed a few times but it wasn't like a
great comedy and that's what I wanted I
expected a great comedy so it was a
pretty funny movie but considering this
should have been my cup of tea it being
a comedy that's a medieval fantasy movie
with questing and magic
I should have loved it so I would say
your highness is a good time if your
other been drunk dude now it's a party
so dude I'm not a big pot head but they
might require that you have you know
something else but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more